I don't know about you but I adore the
lead up to a new console generation what
does that sexy new tech do when will it
release what will it look like and my
personal favorite what color will it be
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
over the past few months Sony has begun
to outline their intentions for the
PlayStation 5 which by the way hasn't
actually been confirmed as the
PlayStation 5 yet but come on it has to
be right anyway let's break down what we
know about the PS 5 his 15 things
officially confirmed for the PlayStation
5 let's start with reassurances - ps4
gamers Sony's ps4 love is staying during
a Sony investors meeting earlier this
year the support for ps4 was outlined
stating they do not expect a quick
migration from ps4 moving to the new PS
5 tech from my own dealings with PS plus
I know that there remains a massive ps3
install base who will likely pick up a
cheaper ps4 when the PS 5 arrives so
don't feel rushed to get this new tech
if you want specifics
20:23 looks to be the time sony expects
the PS 5 to outshine the ps4 not in
terms of sales but in terms of the
amount of people who own a PS 5 being
high enough to begin to shift focus
completely but to be clear the ps4 going
nowhere in fact that leads to my next
point
backwards compatibility and cross
generation gaming a quick history lesson
if I may the original ps2 had backwards
compatibility with the ps1 but it was
touch-and-go which games would actually
work on it this feature was eventually
taken out of future PS twos the feature
returned in the og ps3 but once again
taken out after launch and then the ps4
rolled out which didn't have backwards
compatibility at all this is likely due
to the ps3 architecture being so
incredibly difficult to work with it
could also be due to manufacturing costs
or it could be due to Sony using
Nintendo's business model to force
consumers to buy old games multiple
times whatever the reason Microsoft made
sure the Xbox one could play all 360
games which became pivotal in the
console war so now on PS 5 Sony have
confirmed our ps4 games will be playable
on the PS 5 there's a patent in place if
you want to see it for yourself
it basically tricks the PS 5 into
thinking it's a ps4 and the game runs
perfectly if you're grabbing up
station 5 but don't have enough room to
keep your old ps4 be comfortable in the
thought that all your games are playable
in the next generation and yes that
includes downloadable games and DLCs oh
and if you're wondering the ps4 and PS 5
will have cross save on all games
another thing which I'm personally
unbelievably happy about is that
physical disks are confirmed this isn't
a big deal to many people but I prefer
to physically own my games what about
you depending on your location or budget
etc you may not have a stable internet
connection to rely on to download games
and in some countries downloading is
bloody expensive - and fundamentally
this ensures that the second-hand market
survives into the next generation it's
ok if you're not interested in that but
there are so many people who need to
sell games to play games and that
infrastructure is important I recently
picked up spider-man digitally and now I
want to lend it to my brother but I
can't it may be a small thing but it
does impact how we play games okay so
we've sorted out the legacy aspect now
let's look into the future let's start
with the biggest technological advances
in the current generation rate racing
this may seem like a buzzword for the
future of gaming and you're right it is
but it's also going to be something to
be expected in all games in future years
but what the heck is it surprisingly
it's it's pretty simple the industry is
attempting to move away from say the
character artist manually inputting
values in in areas of light and dark
something as simple as walking under a
dark bridge or tunnel would have
required additional information to know
how to act when the daylight isn't
present this is known as computer
approximation and could leave to issues
like black problems blurred edges
artifacting that kind of thing but now
this is the future just like in the real
world when light hits an object it
reflects or refracts the light this is
what makes the real world look real
you've already seen this hundreds of
times mainly in high budget Hollywood
films like the Marvel movies now the
costs are reducing video games will
prosper from this technology it will
take time to be perfected and optimized
but without a doubt this is the next
generations calling card ray tracing
let's talk about additional Bauer on the
next step forward in home console gaming
and the PS 5 in particular will be the
use of an SSD a solid-state drive
instantly this will improve load times
and depending on how it's implemented
this will make the console quieter the
ps4 pro is like a jet engine sometimes
so yeah quieter machine will be damn
handy but the main point is load times
did you see the leaked footage from the
investor call using Marvel's spider-man
the next generation we call the PS 5
took on the ps4 Pro and loaded the scene
in 0.8 three seconds less than a second
whereas the current most powerful
PlayStation on the market the ps4 pro
took 8.1 seconds
Wow on average of the PS 5 is said to be
19 times faster than a ps4 all thanks to
that solid-state flash memory another
way to look at this is through gta5 the
game takes forever to load up doesn't it
just takes forever
imagine that 19 times faster this is a
big deal
here's some things to consider - now in
2019 SSDs are still a pricey bit of kit
that will fall in price before the PS 5
releases but there are two ways this
tech can impact the next generation
either the cost of the console will be
higher and we'll get to that soon or
Sony will sell hardware at a loss that
may sound like poor management but this
is in fact the norm in tech companies
getting the hardware into your home is
the real battle because selling software
is what they want to do so expect both
Sony and Microsoft to sell at a loss in
the next generation but still expect the
console to be a little pricey when first
released if we are lucky there'll be a
pricing war as each company attempts to
undercut the other and the only winner
in those scenarios is us the consumers
as an extension to this point Sony have
patented new technology recently which
will work hand in hand with that SSD
titled system and method for dynamically
loading game software for smooth
gameplay ok so that makes zero sense so
let's break it down instead how do you
noticed in game areas of the environment
pop in as you walk closer sometimes it's
out of nowhere that's why we call it
popping and sometimes it's a low quality
asset to being replaced with something
more substantial open-world games
usually suffer from this the most
only plans to analyze where the player
is in relation to the world and begin to
preload the next piece of content that
player looks like they're going towards
or in an open world game it would
preload the area your mission will
likely send you to if you don't go there
the data will be simply disregarded or
adapted this to me looks like a
monumental step forward towards the
removal of loading screens in video
games completely remember Skyrim when
you're about thirty forty hours in the
load screen could last 11 minutes on the
ps3 to ground that information many
games hide load screens if you've ever
seen an elevator in a game that's a load
screen forcing you to wait until
everything is ready for you
my favorite is from The Last of Us which
uses high ledges or high walls as
loading buffers sneaky and clever but
maybe we won't see as many moments like
this when the ps5 rolls out in 2020
another step forward in immersion and
overall gaming quality is impossible for
me to show you because it's a new audio
engine the klas is tech to this at the
moment
is probably dolby atmos or sony's 360
reality audio but i think i can explain
this
i'm sure you've seen the multiple
speakers in cinemas or you visited
someone who has 7.1 surround sound set
up in their home granted most of this
comes down to the quality of your
headset or audio device but the main
plan here is to use the fundamentals
found in ray-tracing do you remember
those lines that bounced around earlier
yeah that's the thing they're going to
do the exact same thing with audio so
audio flies towards an object which
either dampens or echos the sound back
it's really that simple once again
making the game feel a little more
realistic we'll have to see how it goes
because in 2019
I still haven't played a game where they
can successfully implement vertical
audio if you play fortnight and you hear
footsteps are you able to tell if
they're above you or below you because I
can't still maybe just maybe Sony 360
reality audio will find the key to the
audio restraints in the current
generation and wait there's more going
back to visuals supposedly the PS 5 is
capable of 8k output yeah I'm a bit of a
sony fanboys but as I am independent I
can be honest where other PlayStation
channels sadly cannot 8k on PS 5
hmm I question this as I believe this is
trying to make the product to appear
future-proofed when the likelihood of
again using this feature are slim to
none in my eyes yes it's true that the
framework will be there but don't get
your hopes up too much I'm not even
certain we'll get solid framerate at 4k
half that resolution in the next
generation I don't need much I
personally would love 1080p at 120
frames a second for competitive gaming
on a bedroom TV or desktop monitor and
60 frames per second at 4k for cinematic
gaming in your living room and again
let's add context to all these buzzwords
currently an 8k monitor will cost about
six times the expected price of a PS 5
8k maybe here but only for the rich and
the reckless at the moment earlier we
mentioned digital downloads and the
future of Internet connections for
streaming and gaming on the Gulf have
you seen Google's attempt to break into
this market the Google stadia where
everything is online at the moment game
streaming isn't up to the standard to
make us all sell our consoles and throw
our pcs in the garbage but just in case
something unprecedented happens Sony and
Microsoft have joined forces Sony has
agreed to use Microsoft's Azure cloud
service for streaming content to gamers
this is most likely to combat stadia
showing they are both invested in
streaming games and more importantly are
willing to work across different
platforms maybe in about 10 years
streaming will be a commonplace thing
but in 2020 no I don't think so
not just yet looking into this from the
outside Google and Microsoft seem to
have a much stronger position in
server-side gaming streaming so expect
Sony to aggressively cut that gap over
the next few years so I'm just too much
what's your opinion of VR gaming I have
psvr PlayStation virtual reality and I
love it but the power of the current
system isn't ideal and those cables make
gaming a nightmare to set up oculus on
the other hand and other manufacturers
have implemented Wireless versions but
embedded the tech elsewhere which makes
this point very interesting PS VR tech
is already built into the PS 5 Sony have
recently asked for feedback about the
PSP R which makes virtual reality a
continued focus for Sony and the place
station of the next generation if you
come to this video as a Sony Pony or an
Xbox or a PC master-race
trying to see what is your best options
for the future one point remains the
real difference here the next console
war is all about first party titles
Microsoft have realized this and began
to purchase many studios so in about
four to seven years that could really
come to fruition but currently ps4 has
the far stronger first party titles and
sales suggests that that's going to be
the same thing to the PS 5 so what are
you reckon where do you like to play why
do you play where you play and now the
big question when will the PS 5 release
everything is pointing towards a 2020
release but some people think we're
going to get it this year I'm not too
sure about that the ps4 and ps3 released
in November the ps2 released out of
Japan in October and November and the
ps1 is a little less easy to track due
to multiple release dates but let's call
it September so this all suggests that
November is the perfect month to launch
but I'm hoping for something a little
sooner in 2017 Nintendo broke the rules
of releasing around Christmas and gave
us a switch in March what do you think
when do you think we'll see the PS 5 if
it's even called that and finally price
price is key to getting these in your
home I remember many of my friends
purchasing the xbox360 because its price
point suited them better do you remember
the ps3 release it was a little
embarrassing as a PlayStation gamer Sony
wanted $600 for the ps3 which was
ridiculous because the average consumer
couldn't afford that this led to the
Xbox winning the early days of that
console war although in the end
PlayStation won that war to the ps4
released at $400 which was about 350
quid here in the UK and was much more
affordable so here's the thing those
SSDs in the PS 5 are mighty expensive
and if the control doesn't change then
they aren't cheap either so what will be
the PS 5 price point have a guess below
I'll buy a PS 5 for the first person to
get the answer right below only comments
in the first week though alright I'm not
doing this until the date releases so
there we have it what do you think about
the future
station I'd love to know your thoughts
go crazy let's start a debate below I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade hopefully
this has been interesting and
informative or just a waste of your time
I'll see you next time
[Music]